[Music]
[Music]
the intro is basically why programming
typescript what is typescript
typescript slang is a language
which is
compiled into javascript
so basically the process goes like this
you write something in typescript
you start the compiler
and compile and you get the javascript
piece the equivalent javascript this
javascript can be used
anywhere where javascript can be used so
it can be used in html pages it could be
used on the server side it could be run
separately as a program and you can see
the output on the console so
the question is
that you may ask or you may have why
bother why should i even bother writing
something in language a
and then compile it to language b in
this case javascript
if i can just
write code in javascript without all
these troubles so what is the benefit
why would i do something like this in my
opinion when i say in my opinion it's an
opinion of a person who spent many many
years working with different programming
languages and most of my programming
experience is in java
java server side mainly i know the
language i know how it works i know how
compile languages work
and being a java developer for the most
of my life in programming i can tell you
that java developers look kind of down
on people who work in javascript they
think to themselves java is a real
language but javascript is a toy
it's unpredictable it may or may not
work uh people make fun of javascript it
it doesn't tell you if
you make an
error if you type something and you make
a mistake what kind of mistake
javascript is a dynamic language so if
for example you declared a variable of
type string but you assigned a and you
assign a string to it and somewhere else
you assigned a number to this same
variable so the type of this variable
automatically is changed to number in
javascript you don't even
have a chance to declare a type
of a variable your hand you don't need
to declare a type
so all these little things
may cause problems when the program is
deployed in production
you write a function that has five
arguments what are they what are these
arguments
are they all numbers or maybe some of
them are strings how how are you
supposed to know oh you're a smart
programmer and you can read the body of
the function and you will figure it out
what if somebody else will be reading
your code what if you made a mistake and
assigned the value of the wrong type
what if you have a function that's
supposed to get an object
of type user
and
somebody who sends uses the data for
example the data comes from the server
side as a json somebody on the server
side added a couple of fields and they
forgot to tell you about it you are from
a frontend developer right so the object
the structure of the object is different
your call may crash your code may crash
during the runtime then you'll figure it
out and you will fix it but
wouldn't be wouldn't it be nice if
you could
fix the problem sooner before deploying
the code in production
let me show you a quick little sample
quick little sample and what i'm what
i'm using now
i'm using so-called
playground typescript playground there
is a site called typescriptlang.org
and if you go there you will see this
menu playground in there
you ca you will see the script the
screen split in two parts on the left
you can type something you can type the
coding typescript
and on the right you will see the
equivalent in
javascript the compiled version let me
get rid of this piece
and
let me start
typing something for example let
x
equal
three for example something like this
i
wrote this line in typescript
and on the right hand side you see it's
equivalent in javascript and you can
tell me these lines are these these both
versions are the same right
it's right because i didn't use types on
the left
let me do this let me declare that the
variable x has a type number
take a look at this by the way and
number see i'm making mistakes i'm
getting help
auto complete
and intellisense right
so i will not make a mistake so look at
this on the left hand side i declared a
variable x of type number and i assigned
three to it
on the right hand side you see a
transpiled version by the way the word
transpile
it's like compiled but a compiler would
compile the source code in any language
into a machine code or maybe into a byte
code but when you say the word transpile
we mean that the code will be compiled
compiled from one source language from
the source in one language to
the source in the other language as you
can see on the right hand side you see
the javascript version of the code but
without the type without the number
without the number all right so
to transpile means to convert the code
from the source in language a to the
source language b so if this would be a
real project we would we would be
deploying this piece of code
so browsers or any other
javascript language
they still need javascript they don't
run typescript so there is a process
there is a step to compile
now let me show you another example let
me do this
take a look at this function on the left
ignore what's happening on the right
and does it matter as a matter of fact
it is javascript on the left now
what i will do now you see a couple of
lines
of uh
a couple of um variables actually
arguments of the function point enter
and point b
uh they are
underlined with this quickly red line
this is basically typescript compiler
complain remember on the left we see the
typescript compiler it complained that
it complained saying that since you
didn't declare the type of this
parameter it's assumed that the type is
any
any is a bad practice and you shouldn't
be doing this they say that so what i
will do there is a config
i can configure the typescript compiler
see this is a checkpoint it says noi
implicit any don't do this don't assume
that that variable has a type any let me
uncheck this
letter see now it will allow me to have
implicit any type
anyway so
the good part about typescript that it
has optional typings types are optional
it's not like in java if you will if you
won't declare the type of a variable it
won't work it will
and that's the beauty of it so if you
have a javascript project with a code
base already written and you want to go
in the typescript direction and you want
to move to typescript you don't have to
declare a type for each and every
variable no you don't need to do this
see as you can see it doesn't complain
because
typescript is a superset of javascript
valid type valid javascript code is
considered to be a valid typescript code
and you can see it over there
so what's the problem in this example
anybody can look at it take a look it's
basically pythagorean
theorem if you remember
a power of 2 plus b power of 2 is equal
to c power of 2. let's see if you it
could be used in particular to calculate
in geometry so let's not go there but
take a look at this code on the left
guys
do you see do you see
any issues in there somebody's saying
you need to type of the parameters it's
optional
yes i need it and i will
show you how i will add it now but it's
optional in typescript it's complete but
it can run yes
basically
in typescript there is an option that is
i don't know if they have it over here
but if you would be using ide
one of the ids i'm using this
playground thing because for me it's
more it's easier to show you something
but if you'd be using regular ide
there or you also can specify the
parameters of the compiler and one of
them is
no emit on error if you would say that
if you if you if you can if you want to
go all the way down and say i'm using
typescript i will declare the type for
each and every variable
then it'll produce the code anyway
if you don't want this to happen
you can say no don't emit the code if
there are any errors in that case the
code wouldn't be generated but in this
particular case
from the javascript perspective this
code is valid there's no errors right
anybody see a problem yes there's a guy
called grey programmer
and he says they're the z member of an
instance line number seven very good
congratulations that you are
experienced person and you notice that
thing
that little thing look at this
i wrote a function called distance it's
assumed to take it assumes that i'm
going to provide
two objects
right point there's a point a and
there's point b and i want to calculate
the distance between the two
right and i'm i'm using see this i'm
taking a square root from uh
a minus x
coordinate
of a minus x coordinate of b power of 2
plus x y coordinate of point a minus b
the power of two yeah i i supposed to
give the
object that represents point a
and an object that represents point b in
javascript in this case i'm using object
literal notation right so
what did i do i made a mistake i assumed
that this point
has a property z
which which it doesn't
so the whole thing would wouldn't work
in
javascript javascript wouldn't catch
this error and i could deploy this
super important code and i could deploy
it in production and boom it blows up
right because i'm using javascript there
is no type checking they assume that i
am good enough
like in this case great programmer or
this little thing may you're you're
right in saying that it may take a long
time to find this little thing and it's
just this seven line piece of code think
of a large project all of a sudden it
blows here blue there so what would i do
with this little code on the left to
introduce type to show you the advantage
that
typescript brings to to the table right
away
right away
so what i would say
you know what i need to decl to define a
type
that represent a point
i need to to calculate the distance
between point a and point b or maybe
something else so how can i do there are
different ways of doing this let me do
this i will declare
a class
i will call it point
right
and in there i'll declare two properties
one of them is x of type number see i'm
i'm
writing typescript now
and
what did i do wrong
i don't get it let me see
oh and
the other options see compiler
in typescript there is a thing called
typescript language service it's like a
big brother it is sitting there and
watching what i'm doing in this
particular case it says
property x has no initializer and it's
not definitely definitely a sign in the
constructor all right so it's another
option it it wanted me to declare a
property and assign it to initialize it
with zero or something
but again it's an option of the compiler
i'll shut it down
and
you know where that strict property
initialization i will uncheck this
option so it wouldn't complain about
that
all that is configured of course
on the compiler and the variable y of
type number
right
so i declared a new type i declared a
new type class point which consists of
which has two members and both of them
are numbers in this case
so far so good but i didn't use it
anyway anywhere in the function distance
and i will now look at this i'm i'll
start declaring that point a is of type
point
but
meanwhile keep keep an eye on this line
and over here
as i type
it'll notice
that z is wrong z is not existing
property of the point type
column
of type point
see it helps me it tells me what i what
can i put in there look at this
i didn't even finish typing look at the
line number nine oh at 12 sorry
look at this
it says what
argument of type curly braces uh object
literal z number y number is not
assignable to parameter of type point of
course it's not not a point
because it has no z
of course i will do i will do
the second argument of the type point as
well see
i am still typing i didn't deploy
anything
and it already tells me that i'm wrong
isn't it beautiful it is
trust it is
you can say i'm a javascript developer i
don't want to bother declaring type
i will never make this mistake you will
you will
we talk about productivity which
increases you don't need to deploy
javascript to see this
this error
now since we are looking at this little
example i want to show you something
else
so how do you declare types first of all
there are basic types like number string
boolean
they already come with the language but
you can define your own type like in
this case i i was using the keyword
class by the way javascript has classes
as well
since five years ago
since es6 spec
and look at this on the right hand side
the javascript code was generated based
on my
on the left hand side typescript code
in this case
in javascript story
in javascript
you can compile your typescript down to
different specs of
javascript
es5 ecmascript 5 even the oldest super
oldest one ecmascript
three
es 2015
which is also known as ecmascript
6 es6
all these every year they release a new
version right let me let me do this
no they didn't do it yet i guess
basically what i wanted to show you
right now
there is a
proposal to introduce fields in the
class in javascript
right so these would be fields so
some browser already supported in
particular chrome supports it but
if
uh
ecmask if it will become the final
version
final
stage of the ecmascript
fields in the class and then we would
see field in there for now it doesn't
exist so it just said it should be class
point with no properties
in here it ignores the type because once
again because
um javascript doesn't have type
now what else i could have used in here
i could have used the keyword interface
interface instead of type
look at this all of a sudden on the
right hand side
on the right hand side
i don't see anything generated for this
point no footprint at all
so
if you want to declare a type and you
are not planning to instantiate objects
of this type
i declare a type in this case i just
won't only want to use it as a type
i'm not planning to create an instance
of the point
right
in this case i only use the
you know what you call it the
object literal
if you just need a type so to to to do
the type checking as you write the code
in development mode just use interface
or there is no keyword called
type the good part
is that since javascript doesn't have
this construct type
it will not generate any equivalent code
if this would be a large uh large data
type for example user 25 fields or maybe
order your placing order or maybe
shipment 25 fields 20 fields 15 fields
it's a good idea to use interfaces
why
because
because
it doesn't generate code in the
production version so your code base
becomes smaller
so these little things already show you
that you can get benefits right away
right away
even
even if you will try to run your
existing javascript code
through the typescript compiler you may
be surprised and it'll it'll try to
compile your code
it's supposed to
be able to generate
javascript from valid javascript
if you had some little
bugs that you never even notice maybe
these they showed up in production but
nobody noticed
that compiler will will check it out for
you and will
say this is wrong this is wrong that
they're wrong
sometimes you will read
in blogs in
in books in articles
that
typescript is a superset of javascript
meaning what
meaning that
whatever javascript understands the
syntax
should be understandable by typescript
as well
so any if you
so
ideally ideally if you will take any
file with extension.js for javascript
and just rename it to dot ts you are
expecting you you should get a valid
typescript program
with some exceptions
for example in javascript you can
dynamically assign fields to the objects
this is not allowed in typescript these
cases would generate errors in
typescript
you may have bugs
for example you have a function in your
existing javascript program you have a
function that expects the type
string and you put number in there
somehow it worked faster compiler would
help you out
now
what is so special about typescript
it's already second
year in a row
stack overflow developers
are filling out the survey
and
what different different
things
what is the popular framework the
popular language this and that tools
typescript is second year in a row is in
the first three
most loved languages people want to to
learn it and use
you